yo Co Ben would have been from Baltimore
and Baltimore they got a lot of people
on that methadone they got people
smoking methadone over there so they got
a lot of a lot of Krispy wiggers out
there doggone that methadone gang [ __ ]
homework ha ha way to work this morning
now during this whole time I'm like
admitted to grocery stores of Lumpkin
school and everything so I do work in
this whole time and I want to get your
thoughts on substance so this whole time
I thought this stimulus check [ __ ] was a
big hoax like I thought it was like like
once many probably [ __ ] like a couple
that started internet meme to try to get
the best society the like panicking kind
of calmed down so that the working stuff
and then one day I'm like explaining
that everybody my dude this was fake no
one's giving a [ __ ] signal check one
day I wake up I got [ __ ] fibulas check
so my thing is though is this just Trump
preying on my generation and younger
generations you don't think about the
future and are very impulsive giving
them mass amounts of money that they're
gonna spend immediately and not think
about it man you know I think at some
point you just got to be grateful you
know you can't think everything is a
conspiracy and look I appreciate your
call man I appreciate the call it's a
good you know there's a lot of things
these days it makes you wonder a lot of
things make us wonder you know it's just
real what's going on here what's really
going on is there bigger thing that I
can't see here I love that I love
thinking that way but I don't want to
think it's to a level where I don't see
the blessings that are around me you
know you got $1,200 you got whatever
whatever was 602 Stute you know you got
a check you have a government that gave
you money maybe say hey that's cool
that's awesome I'm lucky to be in this
country where we are able to do that
you know everybody didn't get it so
you're really you're fortunate right
there you know I noticed in my own
neighborhood they have there's a gym
that's near me and our community center
and they have campers outside all the
homeless people or a lot of them that
want that were mentally able to not live
like in the rain or in the park they put
them in campers they came and put them
all in campers that's pretty incredible
to live in a country to live in a place
where that's where that's something
that's done you know I get mad well you
know like I try to support our
government no matter who they are you
know cuz I live pretty comfortably you
know I live pretty comfortably I live in
a place that has roads you know I live
in a place where there's clean water
clean enough that's coming out of my
faucet you know I live in a place where
if I'm struggling so much there's
someone close to me probably a neighbor
that could help you know I live in a
place where there's entertainment
usually I live in a place where I can
thank I live in a place rock I still go
to the grocery you know I was talking to
a friend of mine from Russia the other
day she told me that her parents do you
have to apply to go into the city every
time you go in and you then then
whenever you get there you can only go
do the things you would said you were
going to do you know the gentleman that
called from Dubai you have to you know I
think he said you had to fill out a form
or something you want to go certain
place you can only go to the market man
there's a lot you know it's so maybe
just say hey you know yes the earth is
flat but this stimulus check ain't boy
so I wouldn't pay you know I don't know
if I mean yeah look into it but don't
look too far into it where you don't
recognize that that you were that we're
pretty fortunate
you know we're pretty fortunate man you
know we just have so many blessings man
we have so many blessings I feel like
and you know gang good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one